[Musique]
avec Sandrine Gomez bonjour Sandrine
bonjour Damien la presse qui réagit
notamment ce matin cette interview
d'Emmanuel Macron dans l'émission
politique événement sur France 2 oui
alors une interview a consacrée aux
urgences françaises au cours de laquelle
le chef de l'État quasiment tout abordé
inflation et de l'état salaire et forme
des retraites est-ce que retient ce
matin regardez libération c'est un
Emmanuel Macron en est à stationnaire le
journal de gauche observe qu'il y a le
feu au pays et que le président a tenté
de se présenter en capitaine au milieu
de la tempête mais sans rien annoncer on
souligne ici qu'Emmanuel Macron à
Marcelé sa volonté de faire du pays je
cite la France du travail et du Mérite
conclusion de l'édito ce matin Nicolas
Sarkozy sort de ce corps le chef de
l'État qui a fustigé hier la Nupe et sa
motion de censure votée conjointement
avec le rassemblement national on
rappelle que lundi il a fallu il
manquait seulement 50 voix pour que le
gouvernement borne soit renversé
résultat hier soir le président était à
la recherche d'une majorité élargie sur
à droite c'est ce qui écrit Guillaume
tabard dans le Figaro ce matin il lui
fallait dénoncer je cite ici la
coalition des extrêmes pour tenter de
susciter la coalition des constructifs
c'est la même lecture ce matin dans le
Parisien pour qui Emmanuel Macron
appelle la droite en renfort c'est une
question de survie de son quinquennat
écrit ce quotidien le chef de l'État
ainsi annoncé à vouloir s'associer avec
les républicains pour voter les réformes
le journal qui par ailleurs souligne
preuve de ce bourbier dans lequel se
trouve le chef de l'État au même moment
au cours de cette émission et bien
Elisabeth borne a l'Assemblée avait à
nouveau fait passer un 49,3 pour cette
fois faire voter une partie du budget de
la Sécurité sociale autre sujet la
contestation en Iran qui se poursuit
pour le 40e jour de suite et qui fait
aussi les titres de la presse ce matin
oui et c'est la jeunesse iranienne une
jeunesse qui ne plie pas face à la
brutalité des Molas qui fait la Une du
Figaro ce matin regardez le 40e jour
après la mort de Marsa à mini marque
Damien la fin de la période de deuil
traditionnel en Iran il y a donc hier
des contestations dans tout le pays les
autorités nous dit Le Figaro ont mis les
bouchées doubles fermeture des écoles et
des universités notamment au Kurdistan
rien n'y fait ce vent de révolte à
révélé au grand jour le visage d'une
nouvelle génération née dans les années
2000 dont la foule dans la fougue pardon
et les gestes de défiance ont pris je
cite aux dépourvu le régime
manifestation monstre regardez en Iran
également à la une du gardiane le
journal britannique qui titres sur ces
milliers de manifestants ici des hommes
des femmes venus on le voit sur cette
photo à pied en voiture créant un
embouteillage monstre ici dans le
Kurdistan iranien jusqu'au tombeau de
Marsa à mini dans sa ville natale de sa
caisse on sait que les forces de
sécurité ont un nouveau tiré sur les
manifestants mais le bilan reste ici
très incertain et pour l'instant là le
régime iranien lui il poursuit son
enrichissement d'uranium
saoudien arabe news qui met en garde la
attestation ne doit pas détourner
l'attention de l'Occident de la menace
nucléaire iranienne contrairement à 2014
nos discotiens l'Iran se trouve selon ce
journal dans une situation économique et
militaire plus solide et ne se montre
pas assez de revenir à la table des
négociations au contraire il gagne du
temps pour faire avancer ce programme
nucléaire en raison de la guerre en
Ukraine et bien tu es rampe que les
Occidentaux sont dans une position je
cite plus faible un accord sur le
nucléaire iranien qui est en réalité au
point mort et on va le voir cette
situation pour Le Figaro regardait
t'encouragé par Moscou le journal titre
la bombe derrière l'axe MOX Moscou
errant la Russie qui était on le sait
l'un des partenaires de la négociation à
des occidentaux dans le cadre de cet
accord et bien Moscou qui a retourné sa
veste plus question aujourd'hui pour la
Russie d'exercer la moindre pression sur
Téhéran je cite le Figaro la Russie a
donc trop besoin des drones et des
missiles iraniens dans sa guerre contre
Kiev et puis alors à quelques jours de
la cop27 elle s'ouvre le 6 on parle
aussi de cette nouvelle alerte le
réchauffement climatique est une bombe à
retardement pour la santé humaine oui
cette alerte et notamment elle a une ce
matin du USA Today qui titres le
changement climatique ni à notre santé
le quotidien américain mais en avant ce
rapport publié hier par la revue de
l'ancêtre 43 indicateurs ont été mis au
point par une centaine d'espères
d'experts en partenariat avec une
cinquantaine d'institutions dont l'OMS
leur conclusion le changement climatique
constitue la plus grande menace globale
pour la santé c'est la première fois que
la santé véritable nom mise au coeur
d'une étude sur l'impact du
réchauffement climatique ici on parle de
vagues de chaleur de fortes
précipitations de sécheresse qui
aggraverait donc des maladies
cardiovasculaires respiratoires
détériorerait le sommeil la santé
mentale en Europe d'Amiens les décès
pourraient doubler d'ici une trentaine
d'années et si on parle beaucoup de
climat aujourd'hui et bien c'est aussi à
cause de la sortie mondiale du livre de
Greta Thunberg la militant suédoise
aujourd'hui âgée le 19 ans regardait la
elle est à la une du publico un journal
portugais son ouvrage ambitieux
s'intitule Le grand livre du climat
c'est plus de 400 pages ont été associés
des centaines d'experts d'écrivains
d'économistes aussi des personnalités un
tour d'horizon pédagogie sur les défis
climatiques actuelles et la conclusion
ici de Greta tenberg c'est que l'espoir
s'est agir et ici donc dans cette
interview publico et bien elle elle
souligne encore que la désobéissance
civile c'est quelque chose que nous
devons utiliser merci beaucoup Sandrine
pour cette revue de presse à propos
d'espoir